There was,
uh,
daddy known as Marduk and Martech.
He was a Mesopotamian Daddy.
And imagine this is sorta what happened
is that as an empire grew out of the
post ice age age,
say 15,000 years ago,
10,000 years ago,
all these tribes came together and
these tribes each had their own daddy,
their own image of the ideal.
But then they started talking
about it the same territory,
right?
And so then one tribe had gone,
hey,
in one tribe had God be and no
one could wipe the other one out.
And then it would just be God a who wins.
But that's not so good because well maybe
you want to trade with those people or
maybe you don't want to lose
half of your population in a war,
something like that.
So then you have to have an argument
about whose God is going to take priority,
which ideal is going to take priority.
And what seems to happen
is that's represented in
mythology is a battle of the
gods in sort of celestial space.
But from a practical perspective,
it's more like an ongoing dialogue.
You believe this,
I believe this.
You believe that,
How are we going to Meld that together?
So you take God a and you take God be
and maybe what you do is extract God,
see from them and you say,
well God,
see now has the attributes of a and B
and then some other tribes come in and
then see takes them over to,
and so you get like
with Marduk for example,
he has a multitude of names,
50 different names.
While those are names,
at least in part of the subordinate,
God's that represented the tribes that
came together to make the civilization.
That's part of the process by which
that abstracted ideal is abstracted.
You think this is important and it works
cause your tribe's alive and you think
this is important and it works because
your tribe is alive and so we'll take the
best of both if we could
manage it and extract,
extract out something that's even
more abstract that covers both of us.
If we can do it.
One of the things that's really
interesting about Marduk,
I'll just give you a
couple of of his features,
but he has eyes all the
way around his head.
He's elected by all the
other gods to be King God.
So that's the first
thing that's quite cool.
And they elect him because they're,
they're facing a terrible threat,
sort of like a flood
and a monster combined,
something like that.
And martech basically says that
if they elect him talk God,
then he'll go out and stop
the flood monster and,
and,
and they won't all get wiped out.
It's a serious threat.
It's chaos itself,
making its comeback.
And so all the Gods agree and
Marta has a new manifestation.
He's got eyes all the way around
his head and he speaks magic words.
And then he also goes
out and when he fights,
he fights this daddy called Taya Mat.
And we need to know that because the
word tie Matt is associated with the word
take home.
T h o m and tail is the chaos that God
makes order out of at the beginning of
time in genesis.
So it's linked very tightly to this
story and Martech with his eyes and his
capacity to speak.
Magic words goes out to
confront tie Amat Matt,
who's like a watery see drag
and something like that.
It's a classic.
It's a classic St George Story.
Go out and wreak havoc on the dragon.
He cuts her into pieces and he
makes the world out of her pieces.
And that's the world that
human beings live in.
And the Mesopotamian
emperor acted out Marduk.
He was allowed to be emperor in
so far as he was a good Marduk.
And so that meant that he had eyes all
the way around his head and he could
speak magic,
he could speak properly.
And so that we're starting to
understand they're at that point,
the essence of leadership,
right?
Because what's leadership?
It's the capacity to see what the hell
is in front of your face and maybe in
every direction and then the capacity
to use your language properly in a
transformative manner and to
transform chaos into order.
And God only know how those,
how long it took the
Mesopotamians to figure that out.
And the best they could
do is dramatize it,
but it's staggeringly brilliant.